PROFESSOR: And today I'm going
to talk about DNA sequencing.
And I want to start by
just sort of illustrating
an example of how knowing the
DNA sequence can be helpful.
So you remember in
the last lecture,
we talked about how
one might identify
a gene through functional
complementation.
And this process involved
making a DNA library that
had different fragments of DNA
cloned into different plasmids
and then involved finding the
needle in the haystack where
you find the gene that can
rescue a defect in a mutant
that you have.
So if this line that I'm
drawing here is genomic DNA,
and it could be
genomic DNA from,
let's say, a prototroph
for LEU2, the leucine gene.
So this is from a prototroph.
Then you could cut up
the DNA with EcoRI.
And if there is not a
restriction site in this LEU2
gene, you get a fragment
that contains the LEU2 gene.
And then you could clone this
into some type of plasmid
that replicates in the organism
that you're introducing
it and propagating it in.
And so that would allow you
to then test whether or not
this piece of DNA that you have
compliments a LEU2 auxotroph,
OK?
Now one thing I
want to point out
is that because these EcoR1
sites, these sticky ends,
would recognize this EcoR1
one end or this EcoR1 end,
you can imagine that this gene--
if the gene reads
this way to this way--
it could insert this
way into the plasmid.
Or it could insert in
the opposite direction.
So it could be inverted.
So this would have some sort
of origin of replication
and some type of
selectable marker.
But if you have the
same restriction site
it can insert one way
or the opposite way.
That's just one thing
I wanted to point out.
Now let's say
rather than leucine,
you're interested in
cycling dependent kinase,
and you had a mutant end CDK
and you had this sequence
of your yeast CDK gene.
Well, rather than having to
dig through a whole library
of pieces of DNA
for the CDK gene,
basically you're sort of
fishing for that needle
in the haystack.
If you knew the sequence
of the human genome,
you'd be able to identify
similar genes by sequence
homology.
And you could then take
a more direct approach,
where you take--
let's say you have
a piece of human DNA
now, double stranded DNA,
and it has the CDK gene.
You could take human
DNA with this CDK gene.
And you have unique
sequence around the CDK
gene, which would allow
you to denature this DNA.
And if you denature
the DNA, you'd
get two single strands of DNA.
And you could then
design primers
that recognize unique sequences
flanking the CDK gene.
So you could imagine
you'd have a primer here
and a primer here.
And then you could use PCR
to amplify specifically
CDK gene from, it could be the
genome or from some library.
And then you get this fragment
here, which includes CDK.
So knowing the
sequence of the genome
would allow you to more
rapidly go from maybe a gene
that you've identified as being
important in one organism,
and find the human equivalent
that might be doing something
similar in humans.
So this step here
is basically PCR.
And let's say the CDK gene
had restriction sites.
Let's see, we'll say
restriction site K and A here.
Then if you have these
restriction sites
in your fragment of
DNA, you can then
digest or cut that piece of
DNA with these restriction
endonucleases.
And then you'd get
a fragment of CDK
that has K and A sticky ends.
We'll pretend that both
of these have sticky ends.
And now you have unique
sticky ends between K and A.
And you might have a vector
that also has these two sites.
And you could digest this
vector with these two enzymes.
And that would allow you
to insert the specific gene
in this plasmid.
And if you have
two unique sites,
because K only recognizes K
here and A only recognizes A,
then it will ligate in.
But you can do it with
a specific orientation
because you have two
different restriction sites.
So I hope you all see how
it's with one restriction
site versus two.
All right.
Now let's say you want to do
something more complicated
than this.
Let's say rather than just
identifying the gene that's
involved in cell division, you
want to engineer a new gene,
in order to determine where
this particular protein, CDK,
localizes in the cell.
So we have CDK, which could
be from yeast or human,
it doesn't matter.
And you want to engineer
a new protein, basically,
that you can see.
So remember Professor
Imperiali introduced
green fluorescent protein
earlier in the year.
And this green
fluorescent protein
is from a gene from jellyfish.
So now we could, using
what I've told you,
reconstruct or
engineer a gene that
has DNA from three
different organisms,
in order to make a
CDK variant that we
are able to see in the cell.
So remember, a green fluorescent
protein is like a beacon,
if it's attached to a protein.
If you shine blue light on
it, it emits green light.
And so you can use a fluorescent
microscope in order to see it.
In this case, let's say there's
also another restriction site
here, R. And let's say you
have a fragment of GFP that
has two restriction sites,
A and R. You could then
cut this fragment
and this fragment
with these restriction
enzymes A and R.
And you could insert GFP at
the C terminus of the CDK gene.
So you could go and have a
gene that has CDK GFP inserted
inside a bacterial vector.
Now which one of
these junction sites
do you think would be
most sensitive in doing
this type of experiment?
So there are three
junction sites.
There's this one, this
one, and this one.
Which is the one
you're probably going
to put the most
thought into when
you're doing this experiment?
Yes, Miles.
AUDIENCE: The A?
ADAM MARTIN: The A site.
Miles is exactly right.
This one is going
to be important.
And why did you
choose that site?
AUDIENCE: Of the
three sites, two
are half insert, half
originals [INAUDIBLE]..
But at A, both sides
of it are inserts.
So [INAUDIBLE] carefully.
ADAM MARTIN: And
if you're trying
to make a fusion
protein, what's going
to be an important
quality of this?
Malik, DID you have a point?
AUDIENCE: Well, they
try to [INAUDIBLE]
we'd have to make sure
that the [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: Excellent job.
So Malik just pointed out
two really important things.
To make this a
fusion protein, you
have two different
open reading frames.
These two open
reading frames have
to be in frame with each other.
So this junction here
has to be in frame where
GFP is in frame
with CDK, meaning
that you're reading the
same triplet codons for GFP,
there in the same frame as CDK.
Also, you want to make sure
there's no stop codon here.
Because if you had
a stop codon here,
you're just going to
make a CDK protein.
And then it's going
to stop and then
you won't have it fused to GFP.
And you guys will work through
more of these in the homework.
So you'll be able to
get a sense of it.
So now for the remainder
of this lecture
and also for Monday's
lecture, I want
to go through a
problem with you.
Basically, if you have a given
disease that's heritable,
how might you go from
knowing that disease
is heritable to
finding out what gene
is responsible for
that given disease?
And this is going
to involve thinking
about different levels of
resolution, in terms of maps.
So the highest resolution
map you can have
for a genome is the sequence.
You can have the full
nucleotide sequence of a genome.
And that's the highest
possible resolution
because you have
single nucleotide
resolution as to what
every single base pair is.
But that's like knowing
like your apartment
number and your street
number and basically knowing
everything.
But starting out, you might want
to know what continent it's on,
or what country is it in.
And so you first have to narrow
down the possible locations
for a given disease gene.
And that will, at first, involve
establishing what chromosome
and what region of a
chromosome a given disease
allele is linked to.
And that involves making
essentially a linkage map,
where you establish where a
disease gene is located based
on its linkage to known markers
that are present in the genome.
Now this is going to require
that you remember back
two weeks ago, to when
we talked about linkage
and recombination.
And you'll recall
that we were looking
at the linkage between genes
and flies and genes and yeast.
One difference between that
type of linkage mapping
and human linkage
mapping is we don't
have really clear traits that
are defined by single genes.
You can't just take hair color
and map the hair color gene
to link it to a disease gene.
Because hair color is determined
by many, many different genes.
So in fruit flies, you
can take white eyes
and see if it's connected
with yellow body color
because both of those are
determined by single genes.
So we need something other than
just having phenotypic traits
that we can track.
We need what are known
as molecular markers
to be able to perform
linkage mapping.
And so what we need in
these molecular markers--
well, if we just
think about if we
wanted to determine the linkage
between the A and B genes.
And if you did this
cross, would you
be able to determine linkage?
Georgia, you made a
motion that was correct.
Tell me.
Why did you shake your head no?
AUDIENCE: They'd
all be heterozygous.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah they'd
Because this individual
has the same allele
on both chromosomes,
you're not going
to be able to differentiate
one chromosome from the other.
And so the point
I want to make is
that in order to see linkage,
what you need is variation.
So we need to have variation.
And another term for genetic
variation is polymorphism.
So we need polymorphism,
or genetic variation,
between these molecular markers.
We also need genetic
variation in the disease.
But we have that.
We have individuals
that are affected
by a disease and
individuals that
are not affected by a disease.
So we have variation
in alleles there.
But in order to map it
with a molecular marker,
to map linkage to
a molecular marker,
you also need variation here.
So the problem with
this cross is here
you need to have heterozygote.
There needs to be variation
in this individual, where
both of these alleles
are heterozygous.
So now I want to talk about
some of these molecular markers
that we can use, and how
they vary between individuals
and between chromosomes.
Now this is going to be maybe
the lowest resolution map.
But I'm talking about
this linkage map here.
And you can see highlighted
that the bottom here
are various types
of polymorphisms
that we can use to
link a given disease
allele to a specific
chromosome and a specific place
on chromosome.
So I'll start with the first
one, which is a simple sequence
repeat.
It goes by many names.
But I will stick with
what's on the slide.
So a simple sequence repeat is
also known as a microsatellite.
So you might see that
term floating around,
if you're reading about this.
And what a simple sequence
repeat is, as the name implies,
it's a simple sequence.
It could be a
dinucleotide, like CA.
And it's just a
dinucleotide that's
repeated over and over again.
So on a chromosome, you
might have a unique sequence,
which I'll just
draw as a line. ,
And then you could have a CA
dinucleotide that's repeated
some number of times, N. And
then that's followed by another
unique sequence.
And that's what's present in it.
So that would be one strand.
And then in the
opposite strand, you'd
have a unique sequence,
the complement of CA,
which is GT, and then,
again, unique sequence.
And so there's variation in the
number of repeats of the CA.
And so there's polymorphism.
So we can use this
to establish linkage
between this marker
and a phenotype,
like a disease phenotype.
So how might you detect
the number of repeats
that are present here?
Anyone have an idea of a
tool that we've discussed
that could be used here?
So one hint that I gave you
is that the sequence here
is unique and the
sequence here is unique.
So is there a way we can
leverage that unique sequence
to determine whether
there's a difference
in the number of repeats?
What's a technique we
discussed that involves
some component of the technique
recognizing a unique sequence?
Yeah, Natalie?
AUDIENCE: CRISPR Cas9.
ADAM MARTIN: Well, CRISPR
Cas9 is a possibility.
Jeremy, did you have an idea?
AUDIENCE: PCR?
ADAM MARTIN: PCR-- so it's true.
You could get it
to recognize that.
But then you have to
detect it, somehow.
So what's more
commonly used is PCR.
Those are both good ideas.
But using PCR, you could
design a primer here
and a primer here.
And you could amplify
this repeat sequence.
And the number of
repeats would determine
the size of your PCR fragment.
So if you did PCR, then
you'd get a PCR fragment that
has the primers on each end,
but then has this certain size
based on the number of repeats.
So in that case, we
need some sort of tool
that enables us to determine
the size of a particular DNA
fragment.
And so I'm going to just
introduce to you one such tool,
which is gel electrophoresis.
And gel electrophoresis
involves taking DNA
that you've generated, by
either PCR or by cutting up
DNA with a restriction
enzyme, and loading it
in a gel that has agarose.
Maybe it's composed of agarose.
It could be composed
of polyacrylamide.
And then because DNA
is negatively charged,
the backbone, if you run
a current through it,
such as the positive
electrode is at the bottom,
then the DNA is going to
snake through this gel.
Now we'll do a
quick demonstration,
if you two could come up.
I need one volunteer.
Ori, find 10 of your
friends and bring them down.
All right.
That's probably good.
Yeah.
All right, Hannah,
why don't you--
you guys have to link up, OK?
Stay over here.
We'll start at this end.
This is the negative
electrode over here.
The positive electrode is
going to be down there.
And Jackie is going to
be our single nucleotide.
You guys link like--
yeah.
You don't have to do-si-do,
or anything like that.
All right.
Now what I want
you guys to do is
I want you to slalom
through these cones
like it's all agarose gel.
So that you're going
towards the other side.
And I'm going to turn
on the current now.
So go.
All right, stop.
All right.
See how the shorter
DNA fragment is
able to more easily
navigate through the cones
and get farther.
So it was somewhat rigged.
I know.
But I just needed some way
to make sure you always
remember that the shorter
nucleotide, or the shorter
fragment, is going
to migrate faster.
You guys can go back up.
Thank you for your
participation.
Let's give them
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So what you just saw is that
the longer DNA fragments,
they're going to be
more inhibited by moving
through the gel.
And so they're going to
move slower and thus,
not move as far in the gel.
Whereas, the small
fragments are going
to move much faster
because they're
able to maneuver their
way through this gel
much more quickly.
So there's going to be an
inverse proportionality
between the size of the DNA
chain and its rate of movement.
You're always going
to see the shorter DNA
fragment moving faster.
So what one of
these gels actually
looks like is shown here.
So this is a DNA
gel that's agarose.
And DNA has been run in
these different samples.
And what you're
seeing is this gel
is subsequently
stained with a dye,
like ethidium bromide, which
allows you to visualize
the individual DNA fragments.
And so a band on this gel
indicates a whole bunch
of DNA fragments that are
all roughly the same length.
So essentially, you
can measure DNA length
using this technique.
What's over here at
the end of the gel,
this is probably some
sort of DNA ladder,
where you have DNA
fragments of known length
that you can use to
calibrate the length
of these bands over here.
So this is how you
measure DNA length.
And we're going to use
it over and over again,
as we talk about
DNA and sequencing.
So now, let's think
about how this
is going to help us
establish linkage
between a particular
marker in the genome
and a genetic disease.
So if we think about these
microsatellite repeats,
I told you they're polymorphic.
They exhibit a lot
of variation in size.
And so here's an
example showing you
a female who has two
intermediate sized
microsatellites.
And if you look at this--
if you did PCR and
measured the size of these,
you get two different
bands because there
are two different alleles
of different length here.
So you can see this individual
has two intermediate length
repeats.
And this person has had
children with an individual
that has a short and
a long microsatellite.
And you can see that
on the gel, here.
Now this female is
affected by some disease.
And these two individuals
have children.
And you can see that a
number of those children
are affected by the disease.
So what mode of inheritance
does this look like?
If you had your choice
between autosomal recessive,
autosomal dominant,
sex linked dominant,
and sex linked recessive,
what mode of inheritance
is this looking like?
Oh, Carmen.
AUDIENCE: Autosomal recessive.
ADAM MARTIN:
Autosomal recessive?
Why do you go with recessive?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Because there
is a male that's affected.
But not both of the
parents are affected.
So it seems like the
father is heterozygous
and the mother is
homozygous recessive.
ADAM MARTIN: That's possible.
That's exactly the
logic I want to see.
Is there another possibility?
Yeah, Jeremy.
AUDIENCE: Autosomal dominant.
ADAM MARTIN: It could also
be autosomal dominant.
So you're right.
You're right.
If this was not a rare
disease, then that male
could care be a carrier
and could be passing it
on to half the children.
So that's good.
You'd essentially
need more information
to differentiate between
autosomal recessive
and autosomal dominant.
For the purposes of
this, we're going
to go with autosomal dominant.
And what you see
is that you want
to look at the
affected individuals
and see if the disease phenotype
is linked, or connected,
with one of these
microsatellite alleles.
So if we look at--
we basically PCR DNA from
all these individuals.
And if you look at
who is affected,
each one of the individuals
has this M double prime band.
And none of the unaffected
individuals has it.
So obviously, it would be better
to have more pedigrees and more
data to really
establish significance
between this linkage.
But this is just
a simple example,
showing what you
could possibly see
if you have one of these
molecular markers linked
to a particular disease allele.
So that kind of
establishes the principle.
Now let's think about what are
some other molecular markers
that are possible?
So another type of
marker, and this
is one that's the most
common one, if I go here.
So here, you see here's
is a linkage map, here.
And you see most of
these bands are green.
And the green markers,
here, are what
are known as Single Nucleotide
Polymorphisms, or SNPs.
So single nucleotide
polymorphisms--
and this is abbreviated SNP.
And what a single nucleotide
polymorphism is, is it's
a variation of a nucleotide at
a single position in the genome.
So it's just a one base pair
difference at a position.
So there's variation of single
nucleotide at a given position,
at a position in the genome.
And because that's a
pretty general definition,
there are tons of
these in the genome.
Now one thing to
think about is you
could have a mutation in an
individual that creates a SNP.
So you could have a de
novo formation of a SNP.
But if you have
a SNP and it gets
incorporated to the
gametes of an individual,
then that variant is
going to be passed
on to the next generation.
So this is something
that could occur de novo.
But it is also heritable.
And if it's heritable,
then you can follow it
and use it to
determine if a given
variant is linked to a given
phenotype, like a disease.
So to identify a single
nucleotide polymorphism,
it's helpful to be able
to sequence the DNA.
And I'll talk about how we
could do that in just a minute.
But before I go on, I
just want to point out
a subclass of SNPs that can be
visualized without sequencing.
And these are called restriction
fragment length polymorphisms.
So restriction
fragment-- so it's
going to involve some
type of restriction
enzyme digest
length polymorphism.
It's a long word.
But it's abbreviated RFLP.
And what this is,
is it's a variation
of a single nucleotide.
But this is a subclass of SNP.
Because this is when
the variation occurs
in a restriction site
for a restriction enzyme.
So if you remember
your good friend EcoR1,
EcoR1 recognizes the
nucleotide sequence GAATTC.
And EcoR1 only cleaves DNA
sequence that has GAATTC.
So if there was a single
nucleotide variation
in the sequence,
such that it's now
GATTTC, or something like that,
that destroys the EcoR1 site.
And so EcoR1 will no longer
be able to recognize this site
in the genome and cut it.
So you could imagine
that if you had
one individual in the genome
having three EcoR1 sites,
if you digest this region,
you'd get two fragments.
But if you destroyed
the one in the middle,
then if you digested
this piece of DNA,
then you'd only
get one fragment.
And that's something.
Because it results in
different sizes of fragments,
that's something
you can see just
by doing DNA electrophoresis.
And maybe you would
use some method
to detect this specific
region, so that you're not
looking at all the
DNA in the genome,
but you're establishing
linkage to this specific area.
You could use PCR.
You can have PCR
primers here and here.
And you could then
cut with EcoR1.
In one case, you'd
get two fragments.
In this case, you'd
In this case, if you amplified
this region of the genome
and cut with EcoR1, you'd
only get one fragment.
So you'd be able
to differentiate
between those possibilities.
Yes, Malik.
AUDIENCE: When you use
PCR, are there [INAUDIBLE]??
ADAM MARTIN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Are there [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM MARTIN: Oh.
You're saying what
causes it to stop?
That's a great question, Malik.
Yeah.
So initially, it's
not going to stop.
That's absolutely right.
But because every step,
each time you replicate,
it's then primed
with another primer.
So you'd replicate something
like this that's too long.
But then the reverse primer
would replicate like this.
And it would stop.
So if you go back to my
slide from last lecture,
look through that and see if
it makes sense how it's ending.
Because if you do this
30 times, you really
will enrich for a fragment
that stops and ends at the two
primers, or begins and ends at
the two primers, I should say.
Good question.
Thank you.
All right.
Now, let's talk
about DNA sequencing.
Because as I showed
you, obviously,
these SNPs, because there
are so many of them,
are probably the most useful
of these markers to narrow in
on where your disease gene is.
And to detect a SNP, we need
to be able to sequence DNA.
So I'm going to
start with an older
method for DNA sequencing,
which conceptually,
is very similar to how we
do DNA sequencing today.
And so it will
illustrate my point.
And then at the end, I'll talk
about more modern techniques
to sequencing.
So the technique I'm
going to introduce to you
is called Sanger sequencing.
And that's because it was
identified by an individual
named Fred Sanger.
And I'm going to just take
a very simple DNA sequence,
in order to illustrate how
Sanger sequencing works.
So let's take a sequence
that's really simple.
This is very, very simple,
and then more sequence here.
So let's say we want to
determine the nucleotide that's
at every position of
this DNA fragment.
So one way we could
maybe conceptually
think about doing
this, is to try
to let DNA polymerase tell us
where given nucleotides are.
And if we're going to
use DNA polymerase, what
are we going to need, in order
to facilitate this process?
Yes, Rachel.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM MARTIN: You're going to
need nucleotides, definitely.
So we're going to
need nucleotides.
What else?
To start, what are
you going to need?
Miles?
AUDIENCE: Primer.
ADAM MARTIN: You're going
to need a primer, exactly.
Good job.
So you need a primer.
So here's a primer.
And now, we're going to try to
get DNA polymerase to tell us
whenever there is a given
nucleotide in this DNA
sequence.
And so think with me.
Let's say we were able to get
DNA polymerase to stop whenever
there was a certain nucleotide.
So if we go through just
a couple nucleotides,
let's say, at first, we want
DNA polymerase to stop whenever
there's an A. So
let's say there was
a possibility it would
stop at this A. If it's
stopped at this
A, you'd generate
a fragment of this length.
But if it read on
through that A,
there's another possibility
that it would stop at this A.
So we're kind of looking
at when these are stopping.
And the final possibility is
it goes on and stops at this A.
So if this DNA polymerase
stopped only at As,
you'd get fragments that are
these three discrete lengths.
Now let's consider
another possibility.
So pink here is stop
at A. And in blue, I'm
going to draw what would
happen if it stopped at T.
So they all start
from the same place.
If it stopped at
T, it would just
stop one nucleotide beyond
this A in this simple sequence.
So in blue here,
this is stop at T.
But if it's just a
possibility, it stops.
And some of the polymerases
could go beyond this T
and go to the next
T and stop here.
And again, this would be
one nucleotide length longer
than this pink one, here.
And the final one would--
I'll just draw it down here--
would get out to
this last T, here.
So what you see is if we could
get DNA polymerase to stop
at these discrete
positions, we'd
get a different sized
fragments, whether it
was stopping at one nucleotide
versus the other nucleotide.
You all see how this is
resulting in different fragment
lengths.
Yes, Andrew.
AUDIENCE: How would you
create a pattern [INAUDIBLE]??
ADAM MARTIN: There
are companies now.
You can basically
take nucleotides
and synthesize these
primers chemically,
not using DNA polymerase.
AUDIENCE: I'm saying how would
you know what primer to use,
if you don't know the sequence?
ADAM MARTIN: Oh,
in this case, you'd
have to start with some
sequence that you know.
So in most sequencing
technologies,
you kind of make a DNA
library, where you know
the sequence of the vector.
And then you'd use the
vector sequence as a primer
to sequence into the
unknown sequence.
Great question.
Good job.
All right.
So what we need now then is
some sort of tool or ability
to stop DNA polymerase when
there's a certain nucleotide
base.
And to do that, we can
use this type of molecule,
here, which is known
as a dideoxynucleotide.
Remember, for DNA polymerase
to elongate a chain,
it requires that the last base
have a three prime hydroxyl.
And so what this
dideoxynucleoside triphosphate
is, is it's a nucleoside
triphosphate that
lacks a three prime hydroxyl.
Here, I'll highlight that.
So you see this guy?
You see it bolt the highlight H?
There's a hydrogen there
on the three prime carbon,
rather than the
normal hydroxyl group.
So if this base gets
incorporated into a elongating
chain, DNA polymerase is not
going to be able to move on.
So this method where you can
add a certain dideoxynucleoside
triphosphate to stop
chain elongation
is known as a chain
termination method.
So you're getting
chain termination.
And you're getting
this chain termination
with a specific
dideoxynucleoside triphosphate.
So these dideoxynucleotide
triphosphates,
if they get incorporated
into the DNA,
are going to halt the
synthesis of that DNA strand.
So if we take our
example, here, this
might be a reaction that has
dideoxythymidine triphosphate.
So if we had dideoxythymidine
triphosphate in this sample
and it's elongating, then
when the polymerase reaches
this point, there's
a possibility
that it will incorporate the
dideoxynucleoside triphosphate.
And if this is a
dideoxynucleoside triphosphate,
then there won't be a
three prime hydroxyl.
And DNA polymerase will just
be like, oh, I can't go on!
Because it's not going to
have a three prime hydroxyl.
So it's not going to
be able to continue
with the next nucleotide.
So this is known as
chain termination.
So let me take you
through an example, here.
All right.
So here's an example
that you have a slide of.
And again, there's
a template strand,
which is the top strand.
And this method requires
that you have a primer.
And what's often done
is you label the primer.
So the first step is you
have to denature your DNA.
So you have to go from
double stranded DNA
to a single stranded DNA.
And then you mix the
double stranded DNA
with first, this
labeled primer, such
that the primer can then yield
to the single stranded DNA.
You need DNA polymerase,
as I've mentioned.
And as, I believe,
Rachel mentioned
before, you need the
building blocks of DNA.
So you need the four
dideoxynucleoside
triphosphates.
So you always have the
four dideoxynucleotide
triphosphates.
But what's special
here is you're
going to spike several
reactions with one
of the dideoxynucleoside
triphosphates.
So you spike the reaction
with a tiny amount
of one of your
dideoxynucleoside triphosphates.
So let's say you have
a reaction, here.
And this this one here has
dideoxyadenosine triphosphate.
Then polymerase will
along get this strand
until there's a thymidine
on the template.
And then there's a
possibility that it will
incorporate this dideoxy NTP.
And if it does, then you
get chain termination.
And you get a fragment
of this length.
But the other possibility,
because there is still
the deoxy form of
the NTP present,
it's possible that
it incorporates
a deoxyadenosine
triphosphate there.
And keeps going, and then
incorporates a dideoxy ATP
later on, where
you have another T.
And so the polymerase
will essentially randomly
stop at these different
thymidine residues,
depending on whether or not a
dideoxynucleoside triphosphate
is incorporated.
And that means for a given
reaction, one in which
you have dideoxy ATP,
you get a certain pattern
of bands that represent
the length of fragments,
where you have, in this
case, a thymidine base.
And then you do this for
all four bases, where
you have four reactions, each
with a different base that's
dideoxy.
So when you're
adding these, you're
going to do four reactions,
one with dideoxy ATP spiked in,
one with dideoxy TTP,
one with dideoxy CTP,
and the last with dideoxy GTP.
And because these
nucleotides are
present in different
positions along the sequence,
you're going to get distinct
banding pattern for each
of these reactions.
But using that
banding pattern, you
can then read off the
sequence of DNA that's
present on the template strand.
So this is how sequencing was
done for many, many years.
These days, it's been
made cheaper and faster.
And now what's often used is
next generation sequencing.
And one the pain in the
ass about sequencing before
is you'd use a lot
of radioactivity.
Your primer would
be radioactive,
so that you could
detect these bands.
Right now, everything's done
using fluorescence, which
makes it much nicer, I think.
And so in next
generation sequencing,
your template DNA is attached
to a solid substrate, such
that it's immobilized on
some type of substrate.
And then you add each of the
four nucleoside triphosphates.
In this case, they're
labeled with a dye, such
that each one is
a different color.
But the dye also functions
to prevent elongation,
such that, again, it's
this chain termination.
When you incorporate
one of these,
the polymerase just
can't run along the DNA.
It incorporates
one and then stops.
So if you get your first
nucleotide incorporated,
it will incorporate
one of these four.
And it will be fluorescent at
a certain wavelength, which
you can see using a
device or microscope.
And then what you then do is
chemically modify this base,
such that you remove
the dye and allow it
to extend one more base pair.
And so you go one
nucleotide at a time.
And you read out the pattern
of fluorescence that appears.
And that gives you
the sequence of DNA
on this molecule that's
stuck to your substrate.
And you can do this in parallel.
You can have tons, many
different strands of DNA.
And you can be reading out
the sequence of each one
of these strands in parallel.
Great.
Any questions about
DNA sequencing?
OK.
Very good.
I will see you on Monday.
Have a great weekend.